Vsauce Kevin here now let's paint a
classic rainbow green
good
yellow
nice
red
[Music]
spectacular and
we're done
because for most of human history
there was no blue
I mean of course blue existed ancient
humans had the same biological visual
systems for observing colors we have
today and clothing dyed blue with Indigo
has existed from the Indus Valley
Harappan to the Han Dynasty in China but
take a look at these old paintings and
you'll see there's no blue
so did rainbows themselves change
no
you can even see blue sky and blue water
in these paintings which means blue
paint existed but the rainbow of colors
is missing blue they observed blue and
used blue but didn't see blue as part of
the rainbow
why because blue is clearly an important
color it's everywhere
except it's
not
when it comes to blue foods you have
blueberries which are actually a deep
purple plants have no true blue pigment
the less than 10 percent of flowers that
look bluish are like that due to the
Natural modification of a red pigment
called anthocyanin the same thing in
blueberries and cherries
well what about blue animals blue birds
a mandrel's blue nose and butt the
blue-footed booby your Uncle Louie may
have a pet parrot with bright blue
feathers but blue animals haven't been
and continue not to be a very common
part of our lives in terms of blue
minerals the Egyptians imported the rare
blue stone lapis lazuli from thousands
of miles away six thousand years ago the
legendary Talisman of Charlemagne King
of the Franks purportedly contained a
fragment of the Cross upon which Jesus
Christ was crucified set between two
blue sapphire gems the most valuable
object the most powerful Christian King
was encased in blue while in the East
the Blue Buddha carved from lapis lazuli
represented healing wisdom and
compassion so basically when we finally
found something blue it was like
this seems important
like my eyeballs blue eyes have only
existed for about seven thousand years
and were traced to a common ancestor in
Spain today people with blue eyes only
represent about eight percent of the
population so on this Blue Marble called
Earth there's not really much blue
anywhere
except the entire sky
I think classical Arabic and Persian
poetry frequently refer to the sky as
the green and up until about the 13th
century the sky was primarily considered
white because of its association with
light during daytime and yeah the sky
and water are often blue but not always
on overcast days the sky can be white or
gray and at night it's black water can
look gray green or have no color at all
water was often green on maps and wasn't
established as blue until the 17th
century green and blue are separated by
only 35 nanometers on the visible light
spectrum making them even closer than
violet and indigo the thing is in
languages ranging from old Irish to
Japanese green and blue were just one
word
it's tough to imagine lumping together
blue and green but you probably lumped
together Gully boy and sini in Russia
light blue and dark blue are known as
gullible and ceni respectively and a
2006 study found that Russian speakers
were faster at discriminating two
separate colors when shown blues that
fell into their linguistic category
English speakers who really only have
one word for blue showed no advantage
when you don't have different words to
distinguish Shades blue is just blue
it's really hard to categorize a
difference quickly but not only were
green and blue once one color for a
while there were actually only three
colors black white and red were the
first recognized colors in virtually
every civilization here's why black and
white come from dark and light red comes
from poisonous fruits and from blood
spilled during hunting battle or injury
and also represents the fertility
associated with menstruation the deeply
rooted impact of the black white red
three color system can be seen in Snow
White a story that has existed
cross-culturally in multiple forms for
hundreds of years Snow White has lips as
red as blood and hair as black as ebony
would and when her evil stepmother tries
to poison her with a red apple she tries
to convince Snow White it's not poison
so she eats the apple with her but the
stepmother eats the white part which is
not poisoned and makes Snow White eat
the red part which is poisoned the
colors are important is what I'm trying
to say humans have always observed other
colors but we just compartmentalized
them into black white and red yellow was
associated with white and green blue and
violet were linked with black eventually
yellow and green became unique colors in
their own right there's plenty of both
in nature but still no one was talking
about blue early languages like Greek
Hebrew and Chinese had no specific word
for blue the words they use to represent
colors weren't necessarily describing an
exact Hue but instead could reflect
brightness or even quality so a better
translation for green might be pale and
white might be shining you hear that Dr
Resnick I'm not vitamin D deficient
I'm shining hey how about you give us a
specific example of blue missing from
the past
okay
a famous 1858 study by William Gladstone
showed that Homer's The Odyssey mentions
black 200 times white around 100 red
less than 15 yellow and green under 10
and blue a whopping zero times the
Greeks did have a word glaucos that
could mean light blue but Glaucus was
more about describing the feeling of a
color and could also mean gray yellow or
brown and the Hebrew tequila described a
colorant which came from a mollusk that
could be used to dye garments blue or
Violet when we did develop words for
blue they were rooted in materials
rather than the abstract concept of
color the Egyptians had a word for their
blue pigment erzio the first synthetic
pigment ever created but after the fall
of Rome the complicated process of
making Egyptian blue was lost along with
the Romans word for it kyrulium since
the Latin lexicon had a gap for blue the
most common modern words for blue
derived from German and Arabic both of
whom made and traded blue in the 13th
century woad began being produced on a
large scale for dying clothes making
Blue from yellow flowers for the masses
influenced the culture's need for a word
to describe that color that word was
Blau the word Azure comes from the
Arabic last word which was used to
describe Cobalt oxide Blue Glass and
Ceramics as well as lapis lazuli the
deep blue metamorphic rock was mined
from a single mountain range in
Afghanistan the sari sang or the Valley
of the stone after about 3 000 years we
finally figured out how to extract just
the Magnificent blue to create a pigment
called ultramarine ultramarine was the
first truly vibrant blue pigment in the
world and was extremely rare and
expensive blue became more more valuable
than gold
painters reserved it for only the most
important subjects like the Virgin
Mary's robe but only the rich Blue
Bloods could possibly afford ultramarine
it took an accident with red blood to
bring blue
to the world a pigment maker named
d-spock was trying to create a popular
red out of Coach anneal an insect still
used for red dye in everything from
lipstick to ketchup he added iron
sulfate mixed with potash which we later
discovered has a useful element now
called potassium anyway the potash he
used was contaminated with animal blood
which contains iron and rather than
creating red he accidentally invented an
affordable long-lasting true blue when
it came to making red pigment
he really blew it
named Prussian Blue after its use as a
die for Prussian army uniforms its
popularity went Global it reinvigorated
Japanese wood block painting which went
on to influence manga which led to
Japanese animation
and it also revolutionized architecture
in 1842 English astronomer Sir John
Herschel used Prussian Blue to invent
blueprints eliminating the need for
architectural drawings to be arduously
hand copied so you can thank blue for
Dragon Ball Z and buildings but clothing
is where blue cemented its use in
everyday life black gave way to Blue as
the color of choice for uniforms from
Sailors and guards to police officers
and postal workers the working class
became blue collar and the explosive
popularity of rugged denim jeans brought
blue to everyone
it's impossible to understate how
quickly our modern world exploded with
color it was only 350 years ago and Sir
Isaac Newton changed the world when
experiments with prisms led him to
divide the visible spectrum into five
colors red yellow green blue and violet
he later added orange and indigo simply
because he wanted the number of colors
to align with the ancient Greek belief
in the power of the number seven seven
notes in a musical scale seven known
planets seven days in a week
four centuries later you have a
telephone in your pocket that displays
over 16.7 million colors with clearly
defined hex codes so I know that the
specific blues for vsauce2 are 3399ff
and 0066cc
and now blue a color with no name for
most of existence is the most popular
color in the world
we invented the color of our planet and
it's changed how we see life
Norwegian painter Edvard monk had a
perceptual phenomenon known as
synesthesia which causes sensory and
cognitive signals to cross and it led
him to see emotions as colors he said in
my art I attempt to explain life and its
meaning to myself
and while the scream remains his most
legendary work Monk's painting Starry
Night represents how human perception
colors our reality
having just lost his first love monk
painted the view from his hotel room in
Oslo tapping into his synesthesia to
express this once in a lifetime feeling
the entire landscape is bathed in the
color of a bruised heart
the color of transcendence beyond the
ordinary
the color
blue
describing the painting he said a
landscape will alter according to the
mood of the person who sees it
but the invention of blue didn't just
alter the landscape it allowed us to
advance from Simply observing our
surroundings
finally seeing our world
which means the question why is the sky
blue actually has two answers
the first is that the shorter smaller
blue light waves from the Sun scatter
when they hit molecules in our
atmosphere
second is
[Music]
we found blue
and as always
thanks for watching
hey if you want to learn more about
yourself then click here to watch my
previous video scapegoats for this video
I want to thank Joshua Trevor something
kidmograph Victoria and Virginia all for
their help now the new curiosity box
just arrived this is the new t-shirt but
what I really want to talk about is this
say hello to Nicola teslath the first in
our brand new PIN series curious
creatures which is a mashup of some of
the most curious humans of all time with
some of the awesomest creatures of all
time on the back you get to see a brief
biography of Nikola tesloth and this is
the first of many to come so starting
now each curiosity box will include
another curious creature so if you
subscribe now you get to start your
collection from number one as always a
portion of the proceeds from the
Curiosity box goes to alzheimer's
research so thanks for supporting all of
our brains thanks for supporting your
brain
thanks for supporting Vsauce